chris shot his movie in atlanta just a
few hours from here in nashville
and he may be an action star but he is
still the same old chris
we are on the set guys of the tomorrow
war starring none other than
my name is chris chris chris great to
meet you nice to meet you nice to meet
you too
yeah okay chris no introduction
necessary
and we are loving all the behind the
scenes action as he tries to save the
world
from an alien invasion by literally
jumping forward
into the future three two one the way
that they
jump through time is by having this band
put on their arm
and um this is kind of like the magic
band that brings you 30 years in the
future
oh and pratt's not just the star as
executive producer
he's also the boss i guess i could i
could fire
we're on day 80 and i never fired anyone
oh my gosh
i'll fire you the tomorrow war now july
2nd on amazon prime video was filmed
partly
in iceland
and the best perk of the job the
newlywed what catherine
was able to join on location i saw that
you and catherine you guys were able to
take in the northern lights
yes that's just beautiful
i mean
she takes such good care of me and uh
that's really it's really good i'm very
blessed
with catherine because she's an author
and so she could do her work on the road
what about jack because jack paid you a
visit on set here
yeah yeah he's yeah he's he's old he's
he's old hat
he's been he's been the type of his dad
yeah he's got it we
put we hooked him up in the harness had
him flying around the set he was
fighting some aliens shooting some
lasers out of his hands and uh
he yeah he has he has a good time on set
he loved being able to have him visit
[Music]